Let's do a few more examples of
seeing if either an atom or
an entire molecule is chiral.
So here I have a molecule.
Let's see if we can identify
any chiral centers, or any
chiral atoms, or asymmetric
carbons, all words for the
same thing, although I guess you
could have chiral centers
that aren't necessarily carbon,
but it tends to be
carbon most of the time,
especially in Organic
Chemistry class.
So if we look here, the one that
kind of jumps out, this
carbon right here is
bonded to three
hydrogens and another carbon.
So this is obviously not going
to be a chiral center.
It's bonded to three
of the same group.
These three guys are all bonded
to two hydrogens each,
so they're all bonded to two
of the same group, so they
can't be chiral centers.
This carbon right here is bonded
to three hydrogens,
once again, three of the same
group, not going to be a
chiral center.
This one looks interesting.
It looks like it could be a good
candidate it for a chiral
center, or a chiral carbon,
or an asymmetric carbon.
Over here on the left, it's
bonded to a methyl group, so
this is a methyl group, and here
on the right, it's bonded
to a butyl group.
Over here, it's bonded to an OH,
and then over here, it's
bonded to an H, so this is
definitely a chiral carbon.
We could put a little
asterisk here.
That's how they often denote
that this is a chiral carbon.
And if this doesn't make sense
to you, because you might say,
hey, Sal, look, this carbon is
bonded to two other carbons.
Isn't that the same thing?
But the point here is that
we're not looking at what
atoms it's directly bonded to.
We're looking at the groups
that it's bonded to.
In this case, this hydrogen
is a group and an atom.
Over here, it's an
entire group.
It's an entire butyl group.
We have four carbons here.
We only have one over here.
Another way to think about it,
we could have drawn this
molecule like this.
We could have had a carbon in
the center, and maybe this
methyl group is popping
out like this.
You have your CH3, and then you
would have this hydrogen
coming out maybe in the plane,
and then behind it, you would
have the butyl group.
So kind of the back leg of the
tripod, you'd have a butyl,
and what is that?
That's C4H9, right?
That's six plus-- C4H9, so it's
C4H9 in the back, and
then above it, you
have your OH.
Above it, in a different color,
you have your OH.
And when you look at it like
this, it looks just like the
other chiral carbons that we had
identified in actually the
last video.
It looks very similar to
something like this.
And when you take its
mirror image,
this is the same molecule.
Here, I kind of made it a
little bit more three
dimensional, but if you take
the mirror image of either
one, you're going to find that
no matter how you try to
rotate it or shift it, you won't
be able to superimpose
it on its mirror image
for the same reasons
as the other ones.
And I challenge you
to, if you can.
So this is a chiral carbon.
This is a chiral center,
we could say.
Or we could even call it
an asymmetric carbon.
It could be considered
a stereocenter or
a stereogenic center.
All of those are valid
things to call this
carbon right there.
And this is also a
chiral molecule.
Now let's look at this blue
example right here.
And if we wanted to name it,
just so we get a little bit of
review, we could start at this
fluorine right there: one,
two, three, four, five.
This is what?
This is 1,
3-difluorocyclopentane.
So that was a nice
review of naming.
But let's think about whether
we have any chiral centers
here and whether the molecule
as a whole is chiral.
So the immediate ones that we
can kind of dismiss-- and
actually let me get rid of this
numbering because I don't
want you think that there are
somehow three hydrogens there.
That was the number three
hydrogen, number three carbon,
number two carbon, and so on so
forth, But let me get rid
of them now that we've
named the molecule.
I don't want to confuse how many
hydrogens we have at any
of these points.
So let's look at the carbons.
Well, we could immediately
dismiss that carbon, that
carbon, and that carbon, because
each of those are
bonded to two hydrogens.
If we wanted to break it out,
they would look like this.
So they're bonded to carbons,
carbons, and then they're
bonded to hydrogens.
Now, these might be
different groups.
These might be different types
of alkane groups that it's
bonded to, so that doesn't
necessarily throw it out of
the running.
But these two, the two hydrogens
that it's bonded to,
are definitely the same
atom, the same group.
We have an axis of symmetry
through that atom, so it
cannot be a stereogenic
center.
It cannot be an asymmetric
carbon.
It cannot be a chiral center
or a chiral atom, so we can
knock those guys out
of the running.
But this guy and that guy
seem pretty interesting.
Because if we were to break it
out a little bit, you could
break it out like that and break
it out like, so writing
a CH and actually show the
bond to the hydrogen.
And this guy is bonded to one
hydrogen, one fluorine.
And then if we were to work our
way around the cycle, and
these cyclic molecules are a
little bit-- it's sometimes a
little tricky to identify
whether you're bonded to the
same group or different
groups.
But actually, let me not make
it too messy while we try to
figure this out.
To figure out whether it's
bonded to the same group,
let's kind of take a walk around
the cycle, around the
cyclopentane ring.
If we go this way, if we go on
a counter-- we'll do it in
different color.
If we go in a counterclockwise
direction from the carbon in
question, we're going
to hit a CH2.
Then we're going to hit a CH.
So we're going to hit a CH2,
then we're going to hit a CH.
If we go this way, we're going
to hit a CH2 and then we're
going to hit another CH2.
So this guy is fundamentally--
this bond is bonded to a
different group than that
bond up there is.
It's also bonded to a hydrogen,
also bonded to a fluorine.
So this is bonded to four
different groups, so this is a
chiral carbon, so that
is a chiral center.
Now, the exact same argument
can be made for this carbon
right here.
You can make that exact same
argument, that, look, if you
were to walk counterclockwise
from this, you'd hit a CH2,
then a CH2.
If you were to go clockwise,
you'd have CH2, then a CH,
which happens to be connected
to a fluorine.
So you're actually going to
see something different,
depending whether you're going
down into that group or into
that group.
And then it's also bonded to a
hydrogen and a fluorine, four
different groups.
This is also a chiral center.
Another way to think about it,
and it's actually interesting
to compare it to this molecule
up here, which was not chiral
and did not have a chiral
center, this molecule up
here-- let me draw it a little
different to make it a little
bit more clear.
So this one, I could
draw it like this.
If you have the chlorine like
that, over here, we thought
about this as a potential chiral
center, and it's kind
of playing the same role as in
that example down here, but
you see over here, this is not
a chiral center because
there's actually an axis of
symmetry for this molecule
that goes through that carbon.
So you can actually just draw an
axis of symmetry that goes
exactly through that carbon.
The way I drew it, it's not
completely neat, but you can
see that that is the reflection
of that, if I were
to draw the bonds actually a
little bit more symmetric.
Over here, if we try to do the
exact same thing, if we try to
draw an axis of symmetry over
here, if we try to draw an
axis of symmetry, we can make
that bond to the fluorine go
through our axis of symmetry,,
we'll see that that still is
not the reflection of
this because we have
a fluorine up here.
We don't have a fluorine
over here.
Now, we can do the same
thing with this end.
If you try to do an axis of
symmetry, fluorine up there,
no fluorine over here.
So each of these are definitely
chiral centers,
while this carbon up here
was not a chiral center.
Now, the next question is, well,
this thing's got two
chiral centers, two
chiral carbons.
It's probably a chiral
molecule.
Everything else we've seen so
far, if you had a chiral
center, you had a
chiral molecule.
But let's take its
mirror image.
To take its mirror image, let me
clear out some real estate
over here, So let me
clear out this.
Let me clear it out.
So what's the mirror image
going to look like?
Let me draw first the mirror.
So the mirror image, you're
going to have a
fluorine over there.
Then you're going to bond to a
carbon, which is also bonded
to a hydrogen.
That's going to bond to a CH2.
That's going to bond to a CH.
That's the mirror
image of that,
which bonds to a fluorine.
That's the mirror
image of that.
And then you go down.
This is the mirror image
of CH2 here.
This is the mirror
image of this.
You connect them.
Now, these are mirror images
of each other.
But they are also the
exact same molecule.
I could just literally move this
guy over to the right,
and it would be superimposed.
They are exactly the same.
So even though we have two
chiral atoms, two chiral
carbons, the molecule as
a whole is not chiral.
It is a non-chiral molecule.